foreign
people ask me all the time
what is the toughest part about growing
up in the foster care system
I was an 11 month old baby when I was
placed in foster care
by the time I was in the third grade and
I was about nine I was adopted
I was giving a new forever family
but it was far from a loving home
I was consistently referred to as the
n-word
the refrigerator couldn't be touched
she cared more about that check than she
did me
by the time I was 15
I was sick of it
I knew that I needed to take matters
into my own hands
so after watching Law and Order the show
thank God for Olivia Benson
I realized something
I needed to get the evidence of what was
happening to me
so I took a recorder and I took some
tape and I taped that recorder to my
chest and I got the evidence that I
needed to get back into the foster care
system
even without abuse
foster care is a tough experience you
don't know what's actually going to
happen to you your place with a stranger
and you're expected to become family but
if you don't fit in if you act up a
little bit too much you will find
yourself in a new home with new school
new rules new everything
when I was placed back in foster care at
15 I thought that that was the end of my
storm
but it was just the beginning of the
next storm
I didn't go back home went to a few
different homes but unlike many I was
placed in a non-profit program where I
got ready to live on my own
the foster care system is not doing a
good job of raising children
unsupported false youth are two to three
times more likely to have negative
outcomes related to homelessness
incarceration being sexually trafficked
the mentotel is severe I want you to
think about War veterans
Foster youth are two times more likely
than War veterans to experience and
suffer from PTSD
this is why I started think of us
because this is the current result of
the foster care system it's designed
wrong
so we approach problems differently we
actually engage those who are impacted
we ask questions we listen we take the
collective experience of thousands of
people who are impacted and turn that
into data and insights that then we know
what are the most broken pieces of the
system and where we can start to
redesign it we work with leaders across
the entire sector people with lived
experience to co-design new Solutions
and then we do whatever it takes to
implement those Solutions
I want to give you an example
we overwhelmingly heard from teenage
false youth that they were being
misplaced in group homes
the system was acting like they have
nowhere to place these children
turned around we sent our researchers
out
and what they were able to reveal was
that the majority of those children
actually had extended family members
that they could have lived with
on top of that that they were having
these very traumatic experiences
we collected those voices and lifted
lifted them up
the vibration of the truth of what they
shared with us was so strong that it
helped inform litigation brought on by
the United States Department of Justice
the Civil Rights division
it helped inform an investigation into
institutional abuse by these for-profit
group homes by the United States Senate
it helped inform in Abacus brief that
went to the United States Supreme Court
that is the power of lived experience
the key to transformation is lived
experience
for the past eight years
we've listened to thousands of young
people
and it's become so clear that there's
one key thing that we need to transform
[Music]
and that is who children in foster care
get to live with
kin
we believe that kin can transform the
foster care experience
kinship care is when a child goes ahead
and is able to live with an extended
family member or an adult that they have
already known an adult who loves them
that a joke can be a church member a
close family friend and what we now know
is that research is showing that when
children are placed with Ken they fear
way better from mental health to
stability to graduating high school on
time
and yet only 35 percent of young people
in the foster care system are actually
placed with kin but it doesn't have to
be this way
in one state in Partnership right we
went in and we implemented some Simple
Solutions like
let's ask young people which adults in
their family they should live with
I wish I told you something better that
is one solution
we asked we went ahead and like required
social workers to get extra approvals if
they're going to place you outside of
Ken
the result the initial placement with
young people in the foster care system
in in a situation where they were living
with kin Rose from three percent to over
40 percent in just two years
in another state we looked at a County
we looked at that State and in one
County they were able to figure out how
to place over 80 percent of those
children with Kim
so the idea that young people don't have
adults in their life who can step up is
not true
here's what this shows that when the
system believes that children should be
raised in family guess what that the
children are actually raised in family
for me I was almost 30 years old when my
sister called me while I was visiting
New York City
she told me that in just three hours
that my father's side of the family was
going to be having a family reunion
they didn't know I existed
and I didn't know that they existed
and so I raced over to Harlem
walked through that Park looking at
every single family wondering which one
was mine
when I finally arrived
worth can't describe that moment
they were kind
they were accepting
they were curious about who I was
and then about 90 minutes in
everything changed
I discovered that I had four aunts and
uncles who had been fostering longer
than I have been alive
in that moment all I can do
was go into my pocket pull out my phone
open Google Maps and GPS to my last
foster home
58 miles away
my whole life I was always 58 miles and
a couple questions away from being
raised by people who could have loved me
by people who could have been my family
the worst part about this
is that my story is actually not unique
that every single year hundreds of
thousands of children are entering the
foster care system and they're not being
placed with family and again it actually
doesn't have to be this way
the system spans over 30 billion dollars
on less than one million families a year
that is more than enough to make sure we
find family we support them and that
every child is living in a loving family
situation
right now there's a big systems change
opportunity a federal decision that
would make it super easy to have people
who are related to a child step up and
say I'm willing to do this and get that
support
if approved we would see three billion
dollars shipped from traditional foster
care to kinship care
so when we work on these crazy ideas
like let's make kinship care the norm it
is actually possible
and I want to leave you with three
things to think about
number one I came on the stage with like
a very simple idea
children should be raised in family
how can we replace the majority of
foster care with kinship care
number two
how do we Center those who have been
impacted those who have lived experience
and making kinship care the new Norm as
we design it and implement it and the
last part
I want to tell y'all we need some help
we need some allies we need you to
become Advocates with us and you don't
have to be a foster care expert to know
the power of family and to know that
every child should be being raised by
family or someone that they know when
it's possible
I'll say this I truly believe we're at
this pivot point and that if we push
just a little bit harder in this very
moment that we can actually live in a
new reality where when children have to
come into the foster care system that
the first thing that is looked at is
extended family it's people that they
know and if we are able to achieve that
we will literally be able to ensure that
millions of children will come off of
that school bus go into their homes look
at family members people that they know
and say I am loved
thank you
[Applause]